DIRECTOR
Ready. And...
ANTHONY MACKIE
Wait for it...
DIRECTOR
Action!
ANTHONY MACKIE
It's an example of opposites attract.
We couldn't be more different.
BUCKY BARNES
I got a vibranium arm.
SAM WILSON
And I can fly.
SEBASTIAN STAN
There are definitely days where I
feel like he's going to kill me.
[Laughs]
SAM WILSON
What's going on in that
cyborg brain of yours?
Gears turning.
Oh - they're malfunctioning!
They're on fire!
BUCKY BARNES
God I hate you.
SEBASTIAN STAN
He's like, you know, when you have a
fly in your house
and it just won't go away. [Laughs]
But you have
a very good dynamic.
ANTHONY MACKIE
Uh, absolutely not.
SEBASTIAN STAN
Come on, I'm telling you we got it.
ANTHONY MACKIE
We have fun with each other.
And that carries
into these characters.
BUCKY BARNES
So what's our plan?
So no plan?
Great.
ANTHONY MACKIE
I'm so excited because it's exhilarating.
SEBASTIAN STAN
It's a throwback to all those
buddy comedy, action movies.
You just don't know if
they're going to kill each other or not.
ANTHONY MACKIE
[Laughs]
SAM WILSON
That little girl kicked your-
BUCKY BARNES
Ahhh!